here's what it is a visit from st.
Nicholas by Clement Clarke Clement
Clarke Moore ah three first names
oh no more I guess isn't twas the night
before Christmas when all through the
house not a creature was stirring not
even a mouse what year was this written
I don't like how it rhymes already it's
stupid to make it rhyme
I don't like when you fit in it when you
got to fit in some [ __ ] it's a limerick
the whole thing rhymes when was it
written 1823 dude every song written or
store not stargazers in the story but it
is just to me it's a song as it runs
every song written by 1823 that [ __ ]
give this song a [ __ ] a hundred years
and then you gotta burn it can't listen
to it anymore you know twas the night
before Christmas when all through the
house not a creature was stirring not
even a mouse the stockings were hung by
chimney with care in hopes that st.
Nicholas soon would be there kind of
basic you know at the head and care with
their like everything's so proper like
not a creature was stirring not even a
mouse
he's stirring stockings were hung like
he didn't say that the hunk we had hung
stockings by the chimney with care and
then in hopes that st. Nicholas soon
would be there like it so loses its
allure if you're just like in hopes that
st. Nicholas soon would be there
instead of be there I don't like you
know
the children were nestled all snug in
their beds creepy while visions of
sugarplums danced in their head the [ __ ]
is a sugarplum
what is the sugarplum and Mama in
kerchief and I in my cap that straight
up is some [ __ ] Kodak black would say
mama in her kerchief and I'm my cat oh
so he's wearing his night cap had just
settled our Brit and settled our brains
for a long winters nap yo so he was they
do sleep in their night caps they sleep
in their cabs that's so stupid also
[Music]
this sucks you know this story [ __ ]
sucks
this [ __ ] blows chunks dude like when
out on the lawn then there arose such a
clatter and just say arose a clatter
such a clatter I sprang from my bed to
see what was the matter anyway are away
to the window I flew like a flash tore
open the shutters and threw up the sash
this sucks getting super V right here
the moon on the breast of the new-fallen
snow like couldn't help it you know with
such a prayer of Clement Clement Clarke
Moore was like I gotta mention titties I
gotta [ __ ] I got a reference titties a
little bit I'll talk about the moon's
titties gave a luster of midday to
objects below talking about his [ __ ] you
know when what to my wandering eyes did
appear but a miniature sleigh and eight
tiny reindeer a miniature sleigh I mean
it was smaller than normal because it
was far away no he's talking about on
top of his house maybe this guy just a
little drop to acid and he's like oh
yeah it was small it's like that [ __ ]
the end of a Mahal and drive when the
little old people come out of the
[ __ ] box and David Lynch movie and
eight tiny reindeer why are they tiny
that's weird I thought they were all
regular shits it's far away
he's seeing it far away there's too many
extra words in this just say you saw the
[ __ ] sleigh and eight reindeer
they're not tiny they're just far away
with a little old driver so lively and
quick I knew in a moment he must be
Saint Nick no you knew now dude you
can't know something
oh well no I guess you could he's like
but we he's telling us he knew he would
it was about to know in the moment that
him more rapid than Eagles his courses
his coursers they came and he whistled
and shouted and called them by name now
Dasher now dancer now Prancer and vixen
on comet on Cupid on Dom Donner on
Blitzen [ __ ] worse names ever dancer
you know to the top of the porch to the
top of the wall at little jump now dash
away dash away dash away all this
[ __ ] sucks dude
it's so long it's [ __ ] shitty dude
it's ended and then he gave presents and
then I got presents and then I took my
nightcap off and woke up
look at this it's too [ __ ] it's in a
whole nother [ __ ] page of rhyming
and then more
[Music]
like look how pouring as leaves that
before the wild Hurricane Fly when they
meet with an obstacle mount to the sky
so up to the housetop the coursers they
flew with the sleigh full of toys and
st. Nicholas - this sucks
his eyes how they twinkled his dimples
how merry his dimples how merry I'm
going through the stump of a pipe he
held tight stop describing him you
[ __ ] what do you want to [ __ ] him his
belly so round his cotton like a nub I
couldn't believe it I wanted to give it
a rub his red little nose I needed to
warm it in my mouth I sucked on his nose
while I judged his [ __ ] stop describing
a [ __ ] fat old guy I gave it a tug
played with his thighs turned out he
liked it I could see by his eyes his
reindeers watched in wonder then I
[ __ ] sat on the toilet I made him
give me a blumpkin Hey I [ __ ] while
Saint Nick sucked on my [ __ ] then he
gave me presents in my mouth so creepy
he's just watching some old guy I'll get
his even know it do it though God
doesn't even know it you know and he's
talking about animals they were tiny
tiny animals with a tiny sleigh made his
[ __ ] look bigger
yay look at this he was chubby and plump
how [ __ ] fetish he is this [ __ ] he was
chubby and plump I came on his feet I
laughed
a wink of his eye and a twist of his
head right there sounds like he came on
his face soon gave me to know I had
nothing to dread what this is getting
weird he spoke not a word but went
straight to his work and filled all the
stockings then turned with a jerk I mean
that's actually how it goes like uh this
sounds honestly like this story sounds
like Santa came by had work to do and
gave [ __ ] Clemente Clark Moore a nice
quick [ __ ] and then was like we're not
mentioning this to anybody and then
finished it give him presents to
everybody else
[Music]
what a gamy presence what a beautiful
favor and then left really quick so he
could [ __ ] the next neighbor that's part
of it No